SHERYL SANDBERG: Hi, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SHERYL SANDBERG:
I'm Sheryl Sandberg.
This is Susan Wojcicki.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
SHERYL SANDBERG:
So I think we all
know, all the Google
people watching worldwide
and potentially our
Google Video audience,
that Google's a
really special place.
And we have had,
for a long time,
a series called Authors@Google
where we've invited authors
to come share their thoughts.
In addition, we've had
our Tech Talk series
where we've had people from
all over the world come
to share their
ideas with us here,
very much in keeping with our
mission of bringing the world's
information out to the world.
Today, we are starting off our
inaugural Women@Google talk
series.
There could be no--
[APPLAUSE]
The idea behind this
series is very simple.
We want to bring the most
fantastic women in the world
here to share their ideas with
Google and through the Google
video product with the world.
Eric Schmidt, our CEO, has
been dedicated to this,
has been the leader of this, and
has made this place a fantastic
place to work for
women and hopefully
now, a fantastic place
for women to help
get their ideas to the world.
Eric.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
wonderful to be here
to introduce the new
series about women
and about the changes
that are going
on in our lives every day.
I can think of no
two better people
to participate in this
conversation than the two
people to my left, neither of
whom needs an introduction,
but I'll do my best.
After 40 movies, there's nothing
more to say about Jane Fonda
as one of the tremendous
talents in the world today.
What I like though,
most about her
is that she's much
more than that.
She wrote a book that I have
actually read called, "My Life
So Far."
And if you have a stereotype
about folks in the media,
and actors and actresses,
this book and the things
that she talks about
completely change that.
And I want to read just
one or two sentences
to give you a sense
of it, because I
think it's quite relevant
to this audience.
"I feel that the very
changing nature of my life
helps to make my story
relevant to other people
and also to this modern era.
Everything about our
world today speaks
to the need for flexibility
and improvisation.
Yet young people still feel
pressured to do life the way
their parents did,
deciding early
on what they want to
be when they grow up
and committing to it.
They feel there must be
something wrong with them
when it doesn't
work out that way.
We're brought up waiting for
closure-- when I graduate, when
I get married, when I know what
to do and become a grown up--
and we expect
contentment to follow.
Youthful dreams then
gave way to reality,
and we succumb to what is rather
than striving for what if.
Consistency can be
a trap, especially
if it leads to being
consistently wrong
rather than stopping,
admitting your mistakes,
and changing course."
She refers in her book
to this as the beginning
of the third act of
a tremendous life.
What I think is extraordinary
about Jane Fonda
is it's such a human story
laid out so well here.
And we'll hear more about that.
Take a minute.
I want everybody to look
around here in the audience.
Look to the left.
Look to the right.
Look behind you.
Do you see anything odd?
Women.
[CHEERING]
I have actually
studied business.
And in the '40s and
'50s, businesses
had all the same problems that
a company like Google has,
and everyone in this audience 50
years ago would've been a man.
There is a person
who's responsible
for this wonderful change.
It's Gloria Steinem.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I like to think,
immodestly, perhaps,
I like to think that if these
two were in their 20s today,
they would be Googlers.
I have actually read
Gloria's work recently,
and she rebelled
against the constraints.
And I'll let her use your
own words to describe that.
But she felt that
many of you-- just
looking at your
presumptive youth
here-- do not appreciate
the constraints
that women of her age
and generation faced.
And she, unlike many
other people, rebelled.
And she rebelled in
the most clever way.
She had a better idea, and
she wrote about it, initially,
as a writer, and eventually
in founding the defining
magazine in that time.
And for those of us who
were alive in that period,
we remember, I remember
how powerful this was
and what an enormous
change she brought.
And fortunately
or unfortunately,
she's quite quotable.
"A liberated woman is one
who has sex before marriage
and a job after."
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't--
[APPLAUSE]
And an even better one.
"A woman without a man is like
a fish without a bicycle."
I can think of no
two better people
to have onstage with
me than these two.
Welcome to Google.
GLORIA STEINEM: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: What
I though we would do
is I have some questions,
and I know the audience
has lots of questions.
I thought maybe we'd start
with, you all have actually--
and Jane, I'm going to
refer to this as a third act
conversation.
What is the third act like?
What does it actually look like?
And you've been
working on something
called the Women's Media Center.
And what's interesting about
the Women's Media Center, which
the press has discussed it's
really a radio talk show,
but it's actually
much more than that.
And we at Google are perfectly
interested in working with you
all.
And I think a lot
of our employees
will want to help in
some of the initiatives.
Do you want to talk about that?
Do you want to talk
about what you're up to?
JANE FONDA: About two years
ago, after the election,
a group of us-- there was
a big question looming--
what do we do about the
media, the mainstream media?
One of the core problems
is women's voices, faces,
interests, concerns,
were absent, just absent.
News is delivered as
though it's gender-neutral.
It's not.
All kinds of things, all kinds
of issues, and war and peace,
and so forth, affect women
differently than men.
Poverty, environmental
degradation, and so forth.
And we decided that we needed
to do something about it.
The great thing about her,
she doesn't just complain.
She says, how do we fix it?
And we began to
talk about the fact
that-- well, I won't
even go into that.
I was going to tell them about
the Leadership Institute.
I won't go there.
The other side
trains its speakers.
There are talking
heads all over that
represent the opposite of what
we believe, in our opinion,
the opposite of democracy.
And they're trained.
They're trained to
stay on message.
They're trained in
a certain ideology.
They're recruited very young.
And then they're spread
out through the mass media.
We decided that we wanted
to create a Women's Media
Center that could do
a number of things.
First of all, bring
women, in every way,
into the world's consciousness
through the media.
Because we're missing both
in front of the camera,
behind the camera,
as professionals,
as spokespeople, as stories.
We wanted to be-- and this
is we dovetail with Google--
we wanted to be a place
where news that gets
missed in the
mainstream media, news
from every part of this country
and every part of the world,
can get viewed, and
channeled, and written about
through a gender lens,
though a woman's lens.
And why don't you
take it from there
because there's other
things that we're doing too.
GLORIA STEINEM: Well, I
think, as I look out at you,
that really, we are, at heart,
a group of people who are mad,
who are gifted, who
are imaginative,
who are pissed off
that 60% to 80%
of the people who
voted for George Bush
thought they were voting
for the opposite of what
his policies really are.
We're bringing together,
as you are together
on this wonderful campus, smart,
gifted women inside the media
who are media professionals,
who are trying
to do their best in
their individual jobs,
and being a support system
for them in all kinds of ways.
So we are putting stories
out there on our website.
You can find our website and
see our original material there.
We are hotlinked to all the
progressive women columnists.
There's a lot going on there.
We are also trying
to unspin the spin
by giving accurate
language as opposed
to what we frequently get.
It's not a death tax,
thank you very much.
It isn't everybody who
dies who gets taxed.
It's an inheritance tax.
And onward from that.
And it really is
a center of energy
to train people as spokespeople,
as Jane points out.
Now the very first
project that we spun off
and we're very proud
of is GreenStone Media,
which is a radio network.
And that's what you
were mentioning.
It's the first woman-owned,
national radio network.
And in radio, talk network
means not a chain of stations,
but a center of programming.
So we have created the
GreenStone Media Group which is
for profit, unlike the
Women's Media Center which is
a 501(c)(3).
It has developed, over the last
year, 12 hours of programming
which is now being
streamed from its website,
greenstonemedia.net, with
2, 3-hour drive time shows,
with women stand-up comics
who are smart and funny,
who give the news, and
give information, and make
it interesting, and so on.
That's one project.
Training people is
another project.
Making accurate, spin-free
language is another project.
And we were fortunate enough
to be given right away not
something as gorgeous as
this, but 6,000 square feet
in the Empire State Building.
So we have a wonderful office.
If you're in New York, you need
to have a press conference,
we can give you a
place to have it.
You want to have
a training session
or show a documentary
film, we can do that.
There needed to be
a physical center
in New York as the media
capital of the world
where people could come.
So our overall purpose is to
make women visible and powerful
in the media.
And that means, of course,
it affects everything.
It isn't as if there is any
such thing as a women's issue,
every issue is a women's issue.
So violence is normalized in
the street and in foreign policy
because it's
experienced in the home.
But how often do you hear that?
We want to make
this kind of linkage
so that, in looking at the
world as if everyone mattered,
we actually shift and change
the view of every issue.
ERIC SCHMIDT: When I went back
and read the things in the '70s
and '80s that you
all worked on, I
remembered the
feelings and the sense
of what was going to happen.
And it didn't quite
all work out that way.
One of the great achievements,
as I mentioned, from,
in particular, your
leadership is the integration
of women into professional life.
Did it turn out the
way you expected
when you founded
the magazine, when
you were so much the target
of opposition and fighting
in the '70s?
Is this the outcome
you expected?
GLORIA STEINEM: No.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Did you
expect something different?
GLORIA STEINEM: Yes and no.
No.
It's interesting.
I think that if we then had
been able to see all of you now,
we would have been greatly
encouraged in many ways.
Looking at this audience,
looking at the public opinion
polls, understanding
there is majority support
for all the basic issues
of justice and equality
we care about.
So if we looked
laterally, I think
we would have felt
very successful.
If we looked vertically,
at what's going on,
who's in power, who's making the
decisions, and the translation
of the majority opinion to
the decision-making structure,
then I think we would have been
surprised and disappointed.
And I expect we had too
much faith in democracy.
I think we thought
that if we got
the majority, 60%, 70%
of people to support
all the issues of equality,
it would be translated
into the power structure.
So we were naive, I think, about
the degree of democracy we have
and the other forces
at work, including
control of the
media, which is what
we're trying to address now.
ERIC SCHMIDT: As
for Jane, you've
been an activist all
your professional life.
You've had 30 years of this.
Is this another time for
activism, as you see it?
JANE FONDA: What do you mean?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Well, you were
very outspoken with respect
to Vietnam, very
outspoken with what
you saw in the
inequalities with respect
to women and poor
people, and so forth.
Is this a continuation of that?
Are we in the same situation
we were in the '70s?
Is it different?
JANE FONDA: It, the conditions
in the world-- it's the same,
and it's different.
We see ourselves at war again.
We see ourselves having been
lied to to get into the war.
And being lied to to get
in, perhaps, another war.
And that is a repeat of
what happened in Vietnam.
And that's discouraging
because it means
we didn't learn the lessons.
And there isn't as
much public outcry
for many reasons,
including there's
no draft and also
because of the media.
Because we're not
being told the truth.
If you really want to
find out what's going on,
you can't go, in general,
to the mass media.
You have to go to various blogs.
And you have to subscribe
to magazines and newspapers
from Europe, or
Asia, and so forth.
It's really hard to find
out what's really going on.
So that's part of it.
So that's what's the same.
And for me,
personally, what I've
learned in the course of my
40 years of activism-- how can
I say it simply-- is
that nothing will change
until women make it change.
And it's not just rhetoric.
There was a time in my
life where if I had heard
someone say that, I
would have thought, well,
that sounds pretty rhetorical.
But women are the agents of
change everywhere in the world.
And you can't
address poverty, you
can't address
sustainable development
without taking women's rights
and issues into consideration.
There's a lot of
talk about poverty,
and a lot of really good people
in the world trying to address
it-- Jeffrey Sachs and others.
And I know that the Google
philanthropy, a lot of that
goes to poverty in Africa.
That work is not often
viewed through a gender lens.
It's not often seeing the extent
to which it is mostly women
and children who are poor.
It is mostly women
who are impacted
by environmental degradation.
For example, it's women,
basically, in the global south
who are the farmers.
They plant the crops.
They harvest the crops.
They chop the wood.
They fetch the water.
They cook the food.
They feed the children.
And they take care of the
health of their families.
And so if they have to go five
miles further to get wood,
or to bring water
back, that is going
to have a major impact that's
going to start with the woman
and then ripple through
the whole community.
So every single issue that makes
life so dangerous and unhealthy
in the world starts from the
impact that it has on women.
And we want that to be a
big part of the work we
do at the Women's Media
Center because that's left out
of the national dialogue.
And our research shows that
women want to know that.
And so we want to create
a global community.
And this is why we feel
such kinship with Google,
because you're about community
and about stories, about
personal stories.
And that's what women do best.
We create community.
And we tell our stories around
campfires, historically, now
around Google and webs.
But we're trying to put the
gender back into the campfire.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Do
you have a sense
of how this change will occur?
Where is the outrage?
Because I don't hear it.
And yet you're so
passionate about it.
Is it that you're
not being heard?
Is it that there's somebody
fighting against you?
GLORIA STEINEM: Well,
I would say just
as somebody who spends a lot
of time going around speaking,
I'm on the road maybe a
third of the time to campuses
and so on, the outrage is there.
It's much more difficult
to get it reported
than it was in the Vietnam era.
Having said that,
it's remarkable
that we have turned in the
majority against this war.
It took four years at least
in the case of Vietnam
for the majority of the
country to see the war.
Now that's happened
much more quickly
even though there is
supposedly not a draft.
Now part of what we
want to do with language
is to explain that
there is a draft.
There is a poverty draft.
If I say that to you, you
know what it is, right?
There is a green card draft.
Part of the reason that
the administration is not
quite as draconian
about immigration
as some of its supporters is
because they are getting people
into the country and
into the military
to serve in return for
getting a green card.
There is an education draft.
Kids are graduating
now with more debt
than the average
family in this country
because tuition has
gone up 30% just
during this administration.
College loans have
gone down because he's
given more money to the
bankers that service the loans.
So if you say those
things, it's my experience
on college campuses
that, first of all,
there is much more
outrage and much more
activity than is
getting reported.
Part of the reason that the
first spin-off was about radio
is because in the Vietnam
era, if Jane and I went
around touring, we were
interviewed on the radio.
Now there's a closet with
a spinning disk being
programmed 1,000 miles away.
There's no more possibility,
most of the time,
of being interviewed locally.
So I don't think we should
get too much into self-blame.
Yes, it's our responsibility
to keep this country
from being the lowest voting
turnout in the world, which
it currently is.
It's our responsibility to act.
But we can't take the blame
onto ourselves totally.
We have a right to
be angry at the fact
that we are being
active, and it is not
being translated into visible
form for the rest of the world
to see.
I'm writing a book about
being on the road for 35 years
just because I'm so frustrated
that what I see is not visible.
It's such a different
country from the country
we read about in the media.
JANE FONDA: Yeah,
I completely agree.
I did a year and a half
book tour for my book,
and traveled all over the
country and other parts
of the world, but in this
country including Kansas City
and really into the heartland.
And what Gloria said is so true.
People are angry.
There isn't quite as much
organized movement to harness
it, but it's there.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I'll
ask my last question,
then I'd like to get
questions from the audience.
Both of you have been
identified with both activists
and, in particular, what was
known as women's liberation,
the women's lib movement.
Where does it go from here?
The women that I
work with now are
faced with many more
complicated life choices
with family, and husbands,
and work, and the pressures,
especially if they're
single moms or whatever.
And it's a challenge, I think
perhaps a welcome challenge,
but it's nevertheless
a very big challenge.
And it's a greater
challenge, in my view,
for women than for men just
because of the way society
works.
Where does women's
liberation, as I know it
from my generation, where
does it go from here?
GLORIA STEINEM: Well, I think
there's a natural progression.
We started out with equal pay.
You'll be glad to know there
was a moment when people thought
that women worked for pin money
and shouldn't have equal pay.
We got through that.
Everybody supports equal pay.
It's known as "the part
I agree with," right?
Then there was comparable worth,
because we figured out, well,
if women are totally
nurses, equal to whom?
They're all getting poorly paid.
So let's compare
them to pharmacists,
who are guys with the
same amount of-- that
was comparable worth.
So we've moved forward
on those, and we're still
trying to get there.
And that is revaluing
salaried work.
What we now need to do
is value unsalaried work.
A third of the work
in this country
is done by women mainly,
and some men too,
and it's not called work at all.
It's raising children.
It's taking care of
invalids, and AIDS patients,
and aging parents,
and all the work
of caregiving and
human maintenance
is a third of the
work in the country.
We have a piece of
legislation that
could make that visible
by attributing--
the economists in the
audience understand
that an attributed value
is not an unusual thing.
You can attribute value at
replacement level to this work,
make it tax deductible
for those who pay taxes,
and for those who are too
poor to pay taxes, tax
refundable, which
would substitute
for the disaster
of welfare reform.
Now that's a piece of
policy that is an example.
But it's actually much bigger
because what it is saying
is we're redefining work.
Work is all productive labor.
And in that process,
we are also saying
that men can raise babies
and little children too.
And indeed, it's not a
punishment, it's a gift.
And it allows
children to grow up
knowing that men can be as
loving and nurturing as women,
and women can be as
assertive, and daring,
and inventive in this
salaried workplace as men.
And until we do that, we will
go on reproducing the gender
roles.
Because we do what we see as
kids, not what we're told.
So both men and women
grow up thinking
that only women can be
loving and nurturing, which
is a libel on every
man in this room.
We all have all these
human qualities.
So I don't know how
to break this to you,
but I think we've just begun.
JANE FONDA: There's the
subject of violence too.
Violence against women was
outed starting in the late '60s
and '70s because of
the women's movement,
the epidemic, the pandemic
aspect of violence,
sexual abuse, incest.
I think part of what
feminism means is
to look at why this violence
exists against women.
And part of that has
to do with the way,
historically, we've
defined masculinity.
Masculinity is so much about I'm
going to bring home the bacon.
I'm going to take
care of my family.
I'm the manly man.
And so when you have
an economy where
in more and more families, women
are working at lower salaries
and without benefits often, and
men aren't, their masculinity
is threatened.
And we need to create
a masculinity that
isn't as vulnerable to shaming
if we're going to reduce
violence against women.
And that's very much, I
think, a feminist issue.
And we, as women,
have to think about it
because the problem begins
as we raise our little boys
and for me, my grandchildren.
How we allow our young
children to internalize
this concept of
masculinity that has
to be earned through
domination and violence.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Indeed, the problem
is much worse--
it's bad in the US,
it's much worse outside
the United States.
Look in some of these
countries and cultures,
it's just terrible.
JANE FONDA: But over 25%
of women in this country
are abused, raped, incested.
It's horrific.
GLORIA STEINEM: The cult
of masculinity really
is a prison for men too.
In some cases, it may
be a better prison
with wall-to-wall carpeting
and people to serve you coffee.
But it's a prison because we
all have all human qualities.
And what we are trying
to do, what feminism
does is to link-- the
personal is political.
Robin Morgan is in
the audience here.
And now, that has--
ERIC SCHMIDT: We
have her book here.
GLORIA STEINEM: Yes.
This is what the
founders of our country
really said about
religion as opposed
to what the ultra right wing
says they said about religion.
It will take your breath away.
This is the stuff you
need to argue with.
Fantastic quotes.
JANE FONDA: And all her
research was done on Google.
GLORIA STEINEM: Yes, right.
[LAUGHTER]
JANE FONDA: She never
went to a library.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Well, thank
you, Google, for helping out.
Let's get some questions and
get people up to the mics.
We need to get the mics because
we have lots of folks watching.
And men and women
can ask questions.
And Jane, can you
take one minute
to introduce the other person
or animal on this panel?
Tulea.
JANE FONDA: I didn't
realize that Google
was such a dog-friendly campus.
ERIC SCHMIDT: She just
showed up with her dog.
JANE FONDA: This is Tulea.
I got Tulea so I wouldn't
miss my grandkids.
So I didn't want to end
up then missing her too,
so I brought her with me.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK, first
question, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
I think that the reform you're
trying to do in the media
is really well-targeted
and really necessary.
I wonder, you talked
about training more people
and getting more
voices out there,
but I'm wondering if
you're putting any focus on
or how important you
think it is to address
just the consolidation of the
media, and how massive it is,
and how hard it is to
get any kind of news
aside from infotainment.
I was just reading
a story yesterday
about how Barbara Boxer had
discovered that the FCC just
suppressed two studies that
came out about what failures
the 1996 Telecommunications
Act was in terms
of the reduction in the number
of radio stations and the fact
that there's so few.
Like there's no protest
songs for the Iraq war
because all the radio stations
are owned by Clear Channel.
So I'm wondering,
is there anything
that you think you
can do about that?
GLORIA STEINEM: Certainly.
It's a spectrum.
You try to start where you can.
So if you look on the
Women's Media Center website,
you will find that there is a
story about the stalking, rape,
and murder of a 14-year-old
Iraqi girl by US mil--
that we inserted into
the mainstream media.
Or the South Dakota abortion
battle that we inserted.
So there are good people
in the media as it exists.
So we're not going to wait
until we change policy up there.
But that is certainly
part of the goal--
to change the government policy
of deregulation that allowed
this terrible consolidation.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So there are so many
questions I'd love to ask.
It's hard to concentrate on one.
GLORIA STEINEM: We could use
some answers too, incidentally.
You have answers, right?
Right.
AUDIENCE: I wish I did.
So I'm part of the
Google News team.
I noticed a lot of the other
members of the news team
are here.
And this is something we
struggle with every day.
What we'd like is
for Google News
to present all sides
of every story.
One of the tenets
of the free press
was that if all of the
sides of a story are out,
you should be able to trust
the people to read it and make
the right decision.
Of course, now we have this
problem that people say, well,
I get my news from
Bill O'Reilly.
That's all I need to know.
You can lead a horse to
water from either side,
via left or right, but
you can't make them drink.
Is there something in human
nature that prevents us from--
is the media just reflecting
human nature by presenting what
people want to
hear rather than--
GLORIA STEINEM: No,
I don't think so.
AUDIENCE: How can we
get people to hear
the voices that are out there?
On Google News, if I scroll
down through a cluster
of some story, I
get Fox News there.
I get Al Jazeera there.
I get Xinghua.
Most people are only going to
read either Fox or Al Jazeera.
They're not going to
see the other side.
How do we get them to do that?
JANE FONDA: Do more
of what we're doing,
what you're doing, what
we're beginning to do
with the Women's Media Center.
I don't think that the
media reflects human nature.
I think it develops,
and prepares,
and shapes human nature so
that we think that there's
just two sides-- right and
wrong, black and white-- rather
than holding the contradictions
that there are many sides.
What did you say in Japan?
GLORIA STEINEM: In
Japan, they actually,
when discussing a serious
issue, generally have
three people rather than two.
Because the whole idea
that there are only
two sides to every issue is part
of the division of human nature
into masculine and feminine.
And can you say
bullshit on this?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Of course.
GLORIA STEINEM:
It's all bullshit.
AUDIENCE: Apparently.
Right.
GLORIA STEINEM: And they
at least have three people.
And even that is like a
drink of water in the desert,
just to have three
people instead
of having this constant fighting
that's all heat and no light.
AUDIENCE: So you're
saying that we
need to encourage the
media to actually,
instead of having crossfire,
instead of having two sides,
make it more of a
Rashomon experience.
GLORIA STEINEM: You find
out who's a better debater,
but you don't find
out information.
However, I do think we need to
think very carefully about two
things.
Are we using trusted messengers?
We all turn to people
we trust and know.
Except we don't have time
to look at the full array
of different sides.
And I was very heartened, for
instance, in the last election
to see that Planned Parenthood,
which has 900 affiliates
and is nationwide.
One in three or four American
women has gone to them.
Many men have gone too.
People believe them
and trust them.
They endorsed a
presidential candidate
for the very first time,
and they are getting
much more politically active.
That's a nationally
important, trusted messenger.
We all have trusted
messengers in our lives
that we are not using.
We really must use those.
That's one thing.
And the other thing
is that I wish
you could arrange to have a
giant fact-checking system
in the sky.
Because the thing
that worries me
most about the blogosphere and
other parts of our new world
is the difficulty of knowing
what's accurate and what's not.
And the fact that there
is even the dimmest amount
of fact-checking at
the "New York Times"
makes them a trusted messenger.
We have to figure out how
to make the new sources
trusted messengers.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Missy.
It's such a pleasure to
have both of you here.
I want to just say, Jane,
I want to thank you.
I have, for the last year and
a half, given this as a gift
to every female in my life,
particularly those under 18.
JANE FONDA: Thank you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I highly
recommend anybody
in this room who hasn't
read it to read it.
It touched me because
as an undergrad,
I was a theater major at
UCLA and was in the industry.
And as a female, I felt
objectified over, and over,
and over again when
I went on auditions.
Left that industry.
Got a degree in
policy, and went to DC,
and worked in the last two years
in the Bush administration.
And my question to
both of you, and what
I noticed when I was
in DC, is that many
of the female politicians--
Nancy Pelosi, Barbara Boxer,
Hillary Clinton-- it's
interesting to watch how they
have to defeminize or dewomanize
themselves to actually play
in that kind of arena.
And my question
specifically is, how do we
support our female politicians
so they can actually
be human, be female, and
be emotional, but still
be productive in that
kind of environment?
GLORIA STEINEM: Well,
that is a great question.
All I can say to
you is if you think
that they are
defeminized, you should've
seen the generation before.
So there's a trend line.
Ever since Patricia
Schroeder stood up
on the floor of Congress as
the first pregnant member
of Congress ever in the
history of the nation and said,
"I have a brain and a womb,
and I'm going to use both.
Thank you very much," things
have been getting better.
But I think one of
the ways that we
do it is to always
say to ourselves,
are we, ourselves, imposing
different standards on females
than we are on males?
So I always try to
figure that out.
And if I'm feeling uneasy when
a man comments on me physically,
I comment back on him physically
in exactly the same way.
And usually, it has a
consciousness-raising in men.
And also, that we not impose
the double standard of expecting
perfection from our
representatives, and we do
do that.
And it does really cripple
them that they are supposed
to be better than anyone else.
We have to look at
them in the real world
and celebrate their full
circle of human qualities.
Bella Abzug was one of the
greatest dancers ever, played
the ukulele.
JANE FONDA: Ann Richards
rode a motorcycle.
GLORIA STEINEM: Ann Richards is
a great symbol of a full circle
human being, right?
Right, so we have
to celebrate that.
JANE FONDA: And vote.
Vote, vote, vote.
GLORIA STEINEM: Right.
ERIC SCHMIDT: As a
follow-up, roughly 80%
of the elected
officials are male.
What would the Congress
and the government look
like if it were 80% female?
GLORIA STEINEM:
Well, I hope you all
understand we're not
biological determinists here.
We perfectly well
understand that women
can be just as
evil and difficult,
and men can be
much more feminist.
We understand that, OK?
In the aggregate,
however, the mere fact
that women don't have our
masculinity to prove is useful.
And therefore, if you
look at the studies
of any decision-making
body, whether it's
Congress or anything
else, if it is all men,
it is more likely to reward
the most aggressive solution
even if it's wrong.
If it's all women, it's
most likely to reward
the most conciliatory
decision even if it's wrong.
But a 50-50 or more or
less evenly divided group
is much more likely to have
the full circle of alternatives
in order to find
something that's
appropriate for the
problem at hand.
So I do think that
a Congress that
looked like the country,
racially, economically,
every way, ethnically--
what a relief that would be.
And it really would
act differently.
All the studies of groups show
that it would act differently.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Josh.
I'm from the Netherlands.
And I consider myself a pretty
liberated guy growing up
in a pretty liberal society.
But I've learned I've
still got a long way to go.
But one of the things that we
experience in northern Europe
especially is that
we have boatloads
of immigrants from
more traditional
masculine-feminine countries.
And what we see is that even
second and third generation
immigrants, and
especially the girls,
voluntarily go back into
that traditional mode,
like wearing head scarves.
And basically not be
the liberated women
that we all expected them
to be, but voluntarily
go back to this traditionalist
mode of society, of operation.
And doesn't that warp us
back to 40, 50 years ago?
What's your take on it?
Is this a problem here?
How should we address
that particular issue?
JANE FONDA: You cited
some extreme versions
of women "voluntarily"
going back
to traditional,
fundamentalist ways of being.
And there are more subtle
ways that it can happen.
I was 61, 62 years old, before
I-- privileged, successful,
financially independent-- before
I was brave enough to truly
stand up and claim my voice.
Because I was afraid that
if I really owned who I was,
that my man would
leave me, which he did.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm single.
That we're raised
to be good girls.
And so many of us-- forget
about coming from a culture
where it is mothers that perform
female genital mutilation
on their daughters, and
where women voluntarily
go under the burqa.
It is terrifying
for all people who
have been raised in a way
that stunts their humanity
and to think that that's
right, to stand up and seize
their humanity.
Because you think you're
going to be killed,
psychologically, emotionally,
physically in reality,
it's very frightening.
And I think what myself, and
Gloria, and other women that
are on the board of the
Women's Media Center,
and other friends that
we have, what we do
is try to support the
leaders in those cultures,
the women in those
cultures, who are
trying to change from within.
One of the things that excites
us a lot about the Women's
Media Center is that we see--
I mean, we just started,
but that we have the potential
for becoming the hub,
the site, where women
everywhere in the world
can come to learn other
women's narratives,
learn how they can move forward
within their own cultures
and the things
that restrict them.
We have half of our board here.
Or all of our board is here.
Do you all want to say anything?
Because these are
women who are--
have you all read
"Sisterhood is Powerful,"
"Sisterhood is Global"?
Well, the editor or
the author of that
is Robin Morgan who's here.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, and while you're
coming, Carol Jenkins
is our chair of the board.
Carol Jenkins.
[APPLAUSE]
GLORIA STEINEM: NBC anchorwoman.
So there are two
media professionals.
So those are from the inside.
JANE FONDA: Gloria
Feldt, who was
the president of the Planned
Parenthood of America.
[APPLAUSE]
I wanted to introduce
Helen and Christina.
GLORIA STEINEM: Helen Zia.
Where's Helen?
JANE FONDA: Helen
is right there.
GLORIA STEINEM: Helen Zia,
who was, I'm proud to say,
an editor at "Ms." magazine
but who now has gone on
to even bigger and
more amazing things,
is a resident of San
Francisco, and was
head of the Asian American
Journalists Association.
Well, I could give
their whole pedigree.
But anyway.
JANE FONDA: And
Christina Azocar.
GLORIA STEINEM: And Christina.
Right.
ROBIN MORGAN: I just want
to say a quick word, which
is this is so fucking awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
I now know how it must
feel to-- as if they
refound-- I'm in the Library of
Alexandria, that's where I am.
We have refound the
Library of Alexandria.
There were friends who
said, with this new book,
with "Fighting Words," my
god, with the research--
shorts, factoids, soundbites
that the founders were really
radicals.
Not so good on slaves,
not so good on women,
but on separation of church
and state, the real thing.
I still have some friends
in my generation who
run with pterodactyls,
and who said, my god,
you must have spent weeks
and weeks in the library.
And I said, what are you?
Crazy?
I never left the house.
So everything that Jane,
and Gloria, and Eric
have said so superbly, yes to.
And we need you.
You are the future.
For women of the global
south about whom everything
is building community
and for women
all over the world
about whom everything--
we were on personal
content before you were.
That is what the women's
movement's been about.
So just keep doing it.
Feed us your ideas.
Tell us what we should be
doing with this magic next step
in evolution, which is this
new communications revolution,
and with Google's place in it.
I'm a Googler.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: She's a really
hard act to follow,
but at least I have gray hair.
I have one comment
and then a question.
My comment is I'm 61, and
I'm a professor at Stanford.
This is the first time I've
ever gotten up to a microphone
to ask a question.
And I noticed the
reason I got up
is because of the first
four people who got up,
three were men and
one was a woman,
and I said, I have to
get up and say that.
Because even in this
audience, the men
were quicker on
the draw and felt
more legitimate about
jumping up to ask a question.
And I think that
that says something
about what is the
underlying set of issues.
And now my question, which
relates to the underlying
set of issues, which
is that what I'm seeing
among the young people,
who I'm teaching
and who I'm seeing
through my children,
is that young women, many of
whom have had feminist mothers,
are seeing how difficult it
is to, quote, "have it all."
And that working full-time
and having quality time
with their children-- which
is all the stuff that they're
hearing-- just seems impossible.
And I think indeed, it is.
And what is not
happening is the men
are not feeling
that they dare risk
their careers to be at home.
Betty Friedan had
said that that's
where the problem
is, that we have not
changed the cultural
view of what a family is,
of what men should do.
You've talked about it.
But I ask if you have any
ideas about how to really begin
to allow men to be at home
so that children can really
get both parents,
and women can be
able to do what they
want to do and not
feel forced into part-time.
GLORIA STEINEM: Yeah,
you put your finger--
when I was talking
about redefining
work, that was part of it.
But we are at the
place you described.
We have convinced the
majority of everybody
that women can do what
men can do, which is huge.
But we haven't even begun to
convince ourselves that men
can do what women can do.
And so children are growing
up with much too little father
and too much mother.
And men are not developing all
the qualities that are wrongly
called feminine
but are just human,
that are developed by
both raising children
and being raised
to raise children,
so that you become
a whole person.
Much of it, I think,
is-- well, you
don't know where
to begin exactly,
so I won't say "much of it."
But part of it is that
young women are not yet
angry about this.
I think that will be
the next big stage.
Because women's pattern
of activism is usually--
I'm sure everybody in
this room is an exception,
but anyway-- is the reverse
of men's where we're
conservative when we're young.
We don't make waves
when we're young.
And we get steadily more
radical and trouble-making
as we get older.
Whereas men tend to
be rebellious in youth
and get more conservative.
Because men gain power with age.
Women lose power with age.
It makes sense.
Therefore, young women
are still assuming
they have to do it all.
And I must say, the
women's movement
never said "have it all."
We always knew that that was the
enemy of the women's movement
saying that.
If having it all means doing
it all, it's not possible.
You can't have two
full-time jobs.
So we need to start at
the microcosm of ourselves
in the household saying no.
Them what cooks can also eat.
I'm not cooking.
A woman in an audience
stood up and said that she
was worried about this.
So she just had a baby, and
she went away for three weeks
and left her husband
with the new baby
because she realized that
he would not learn unless he
had to, just like she did.
And the audience went-- [GASP]
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
did they survive?
GLORIA STEINEM:
Yeah, they survived.
Some of it is control.
In women, it's the get out
of my kitchen syndrome.
It's my house,
I'm going to cook.
We have to look
at the microcosm,
and are we really expecting
this kind of change?
And we have to look
at the macrocosm
and get work patterns that
allow both women and men to be
the parents, the nurturing
parents, of babies
and little children.
So that you can work a three-day
week, or a shorter day,
or what every other developed
country in the world
has more than we do, which
are flexible work patterns
and child care.
We're the only
industrial democracy
or whatever we are-- do
we still say "industrial"?
No.
"Technological"?
Whatever we are.
Do we still say "democracy"?
Anyway, that doesn't have a
national system of child care.
Kids need to see each other.
They get very bored
with looking at grownup
knees and the television set.
So you can start at the
policy, political end,
and you can start
at the personal end.
And we'll meet in the
middle in a revolution.
JANE FONDA: We could
take a good look
at what the Netherlands does.
They're not perfect, but
you're way ahead of us.
ERIC SCHMIDT: We have time
for a few more questions.
So why don't we have the
folks here, lined up,
ask their questions
reasonably quickly.
Go ahead, and we'll see you
get some quick answers as well.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
wanted to tell you
it's a pleasure
to have you here.
And I thank you so
much for what you've
done for everybody, especially
for me at Berkeley in the '70s.
I wouldn't be here at
Google, I don't think,
if I hadn't been
so taken by what
you both did then, and stood up,
and gave us a voice and power.
So I wanted to thank you.
That was my first part.
There's a couple more parts.
One more part is
that if, somehow,
you are partnering
with Google, I
would be thrilled to help
you in some way to make
the full circle to come back.
I do QA, and I would be
glad to do some kind of QA.
I would be thrilled.
And then the third
part of it-- I
know you touched upon
it with your question--
is I am just really scared about
the rise of fundamentalism.
It's not just one religion.
We have it here in our country.
And as a feminist, I am
so worried for the women
who are oppressed again.
We can have an influence
in our country,
and hopefully, we'll stand up
and show the world something
about it.
But I do worry about that.
And I was wondering
about your thoughts.
GLORIA STEINEM:
Well, I don't know.
Jane, do you want--
fundamentalism.
Well, this is the point at
which I get in deep trouble, OK?
But anyway.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: And I'm not
picking on any religion.
GLORIA STEINEM:
Monotheism was invented
to put God into one
kind of human being,
not into nature, to make
it OK to dominate nature,
to make it OK to dominate women.
The rise of fundamentalism
is precisely
to put down the worldwide
rebellion of women,
and it also has all
kinds of racial aspects.
It is politics in
the sky, really.
And the first thing I think
we have to do, especially
in this country, is to stop
being afraid of discussing it.
We have allowed religion
to be off-limits as an area
of discussion because,
well, you know.
But when it is political
and oppressive,
we have to be able to name it.
And that's what's so
great about Robin's book,
because you see that
our founders were
saying exactly that.
You can't have a
democracy with priests.
We shouldn't even have
chaplains in Congress.
Jefferson sat in the White
House and edited everything
undemocratic out of the Bible.
Can you imagine anybody even
criticizing the Bible now?
Saying, hello?
Maybe the Gnostic Gospels
were much more authoritative.
Jesus never said he
was the Son of God.
There's a world there that
we are afraid to approach
and therefore, is crushing
us, because it knows
very well what its purpose is.
And we're afraid to
name its purpose.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Let's go
to our next question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my mom was a member
of the National Organization
of Women in the Mother's Day
march in Chicago in 1980,
and did sit-ins in college,
and was taking action
to support women's rights,
and thinks so highly of you
both for all of your
action and leadership.
And I don't see a
woman of my age doing
that, including myself.
And how did you
have the strength
to take that leadership
role, and really
put yourself out there,
and really message
and communicate to
the public, and lead
people to march and raise
awareness of these issues?
Because I feel like we need
that now for women and men.
And I see that there's
a leadership vacuum.
And is it the media?
And maybe if there was more
awareness of what was actually
happening, people
would find a way
to drive that anger and
frustration to actually doing
something.
Because in the last election, I
didn't go to whatever-- Ohio--
and knock on doors.
And I think a lot of people are
in this sort of complacency.
I can't believe it, but I'm
not willing to do something.
JANE FONDA: A lot of people did
though, go and knock on doors.
AUDIENCE: Oh, they did?
Yeah, and I hope in
the next election,
I want to connect
with some group that
is going to go and do that.
But I feel like
that spirit was so
alive in my parents'
generation in a way
that I certainly didn't
see it on my college
campus in Florida.
And I don't know.
How do we train the leaders
to really take that next--
are you training new leaders?
GLORIA STEINEM: We are training.
The Women's Media Center
is-- the wonderful woman
who was age 60, the one
who got up and said this
is the first time she spoke.
We're trying to help women
find their voices young,
and get out there in the
media, and spread it.
But I must say that
part of the reason
you know Jane and me was
because there were so few of us.
Now, it seems to me,
there's so many of you.
We were like six crazy
people at the time.
[LAUGHTER]
And there are many,
many, many more now.
And therefore, you don't see
the same kind of individuation.
But it is present.
It is absolutely present.
And whether you're getting
politics in song lyrics
with Ani DiFranco, whoever.
That didn't exist before.
With June Moon Honeymoon.
Now you've got a CR
group just in your iPod.
Or whether it's on campus
with the majority opinion.
But it does require us to
say, how am I translating this
into action?
And what you just said was
the answer, that you're going
to do it this time, right?
ERIC SCHMIDT: That's right.
Let's have a couple
more quickly,
and then we'll be-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I'm just in awe.
And I read every
bit of Ms. Magazine,
and it really totally
changed my life.
And just that you
came to Google,
that we're not selling out,
and working for ourselves,
that working for a corporation,
we could also work for a cause.
So it means a lot to me.
Anyway, my question was,
when I read feminism,
sometimes, we have
to work with theory
because we have to have vision.
And it tends to be very white.
And I grew up very sort of
white, so it speaks to me,
but I really-- what is
your vision of feminism?
Diverse yet very unified?
Because I see it going
to environmentalism
and all these other things.
But what is your vision for now?
And I'm fine with changes,
and I know visions change.
But I would just like to
hear that since you're here,
and I would like that slice.
And thank you so
much for coming.
GLORIA STEINEM: Thank you.
JANE FONDA: I just want to
say one thing personally.
I go to the Interdenominational
Theological Center in Atlanta.
It's the largest training center
for African American ministers
and me.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm the only white
student there.
And a couple of the
classes that I'm taking
is Womanist Interpretation.
And I am in this school
surrounded by black--
their word is womanist.
It comes from Alice Walker's
writings, "My Mother's Garden."
Feminism, womanism, it's there.
And it's women of all color.
And I personally
have experienced it.
And it's proof to
me of how far we've
come from an all-white,
middle class movement
to a global, really
global, multiracial,
multiethnicity movement.
It's there.
I just came back
from Sweden where
there was a feminist
candidate running for office.
And a bunch of us
went just to show
that it's a global movement.
GLORIA STEINEM: The
president of Liberia
who basically won because
women in the marketplace
could vote in the marketplace.
And also because when they
couldn't reach an agreement,
and it was mainly men reaching
an agreement-- the preface
to the election-- the women
surrounded the building
and wouldn't let them out.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Let's
get our next question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I'm a big believer in the
power of women's institutions.
I went to an
undergraduate college that
was an all-women
college and believe
that women's groups have
been a big agent for change.
But I struggle with
the idea that when
you label something a women's
group, or women's media,
that it gives more
credence to the idea
that the mainstream
institution is still for men.
It makes it easier to
belittle or sideline.
So I'm just wondering how you
see the future of these groups,
and how we can best integrate
our ideas into the mainstream.
GLORIA STEINEM: Well, I
envision it like this.
You've got a
powerful group here,
you've got a less
whether it's because
of any reason-- gender,
ethnicity, whatever it is.
If you integrate at this point,
you come into a hierarchy.
What you have to do is empower
this group to get up here,
and then you can come together.
So the coming together is the
goal, but the path to the goal
is to become visible, to move
from the margins to the center,
to have a voice,
to be able to say.
So labeling things
in that way is
a step towards not having
to label them eventually.
And we need to keep saying
what the end goal is, I agree,
so that we don't think that
separation is the goal.
It is not.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you.
And you will have the
honor of the last question.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I don't know whether I'm
thrilled or intimidated.
But I want to say thank
you again for coming.
I'm thrilled to be here
and hear the two of you.
Actually, I want to
end this by bringing
it closer to what I
think is something
relevant to the women in this
audience, which is there's
this brand new report out by
the National Academy of Sciences
about women leadership in
science and engineering.
And essentially
refuting everything
that Larry Summers said,
and saying that it's not
differences in ability.
It's essentially the
death by a thousand cuts
and the small little
things that happen
to women over the
course of their career
that end up holding them back.
And the fact that we
have so many fewer women
leaders in science and
technology than the pipeline
would suggest.
Many of the women
in this audience
are living that pipeline,
living the route
to potentially being a woman
leader in the sciences field.
Do you have any
thoughts of this?
How to overcome.
How to stay steadfast through
these thousands of small things
that aren't even noticed
by the participants,
neither the men or the women.
GLORIA STEINEM: She's
turning to me, the engineer.
No.
Well, I think you need
each others' support--
women who are going through the
struggle, men who understand
it and are supportive.
We're communal creatures.
If we're by ourselves,
we come to feel crazy,
and alone, and immobilized.
You need people to talk to about
what's happening to you once
a week, once a month, get
together, call it whatever--
a CR group, a networking group,
a book club, a quilting bee.
I don't care what you
call it, but someplace
where you can talk
about it, and get
support, and pool information.
I think that's
absolutely crucial.
And then also, we need
to look at the way
that the inclusion of other
groups transforms the outcome.
There's a whole amazing feminist
critique of anthropology,
and the feminist critique of
the scientific method that
says, wait a minute,
your hypothesis
dictates the whole thing.
And what you get in the
laboratory is only replicate.
All that argument,
which is fascinating.
And we need to start our
own centers of power,
like the Women's Media Center.
My college, Smith College,
is the only women's college,
I think, with an
engineering school.
Why?
Because the young women
were going to UMass,
and were not getting
called on, and whatever.
And this went on for years,
and years, and years.
And they got pissed.
And they started their
own engineering school
on the premise that not
only would engineering
change women-- to give
them knowledge, and power,
and so on-- but women
would change engineering
in all of its different
permutations and fields.
So again, the environmentalists
are right-- act locally
and think globally.
It's starting with the
intimate, with ourselves,
and keeping our strength up,
and keeping our vision up,
and also going to change
the structure in the policy.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you so
much for taking the time
to come here.
In the last hour,
we've talked a lot
about the sense of
activism and the role
that everybody has played.
But I could think of no
better examples of impact
on the world than
the two of you.
I think all of us can only hope
to have the level of impact
on society as a
whole as you have
done in the first two
of your three acts.
And since it's going to get more
interesting as you get older,
I'm very much looking
forward to their third act.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
GLORIA STEINEM: Thank you.
JANE FONDA: Thank you.